okay I want to talk a little bit because
we are talking more and more about
Donald Trump's tax proposal which we
analyzed in detail last week Republicans
are responsible for creating some very
stick to the wall myths about tax cuts
myths that have really stuck around and
are often repeated for example they like
to say that high taxes and high tax
rates created stagflation in the 1970s
so stagflation is high inflation plus
high unemployment with sort of stagnant
demand in a country's economy they like
to say that Reagan cutting taxes back in
1981 for example launched this amazing
period of economic growth that is a lot
of what the supply-side defenders base
their defense of cutting taxes for the
rich on and when you look into the
details it falls apart in an instant the
truth is that there was a huge interest
rate reduction by the Federal Reserve
that coincided it with Ronald Reagan's
actions in the early 80s when you cut
the federal funds rate that stimulates
the economy in the short run now there's
debates to be had and we've had them and
all sorts of economists from Robert
Reich to Paul Krugman and right-wing
economists have weighed in on the impact
of low federal funds interest rates over
the long term but in the short term you
have huge economic optics as a result of
lowering of the federal funds rate in
addition at the same time that Reagan
was doing this there was major
infrastructure spending this included
highway construction that combined with
the end of the recession that had been
taking place is actually what's
responsible for the optimistic positive
economic indicators that coincided but
did not were not caused by Ronald
Reagan's adjustments to taxes another
canard from the low tax right is if you
cut taxes for the rich it's good for the
economy
I guess because either the rich will
spend their money or they'll hire people
in their businesses or for some other
reasons but that's a common one from the
right the reality is that's just not
true and I've explained this concept
before it's the economic concept
of the marginal propensity to consume if
you're really rich and your taxes are
lowered and now you have a little more
money you never needed that money for
your day-to-day life unless you're
incredibly bad with money so you're not
that likely to reinsert that money into
the economy you're probably gonna save a
lot of that money if you give a tax cut
to people who earn a lot less where they
would use that tax cut to fund their
day-to-day life that is way more
economically stimulative so that
argument doesn't make any sense then you
go to corporations the right likes to
say American corporations are just too
highly taxed let's cut taxes for
corporations and it'll stimulate the
economy that makes absolutely no sense
capital investment by business owners is
already tax-deductible when you think
about what that means if you are a
business owner and the tax rate is
really high you can avoid a high tax
rate by investing money in your business
because it lowers your taxable income in
fact that suggests that higher corporate
tax rates actually would incentivize
businesses to reinvest capital by buying
stuff or improving or hiring or whatever
but it actually doesn't make sense
either and I've been clear about why
because Donald Trump's tax proposal for
me it would be good right I have a
business that is a corporation and S
corporation
meaning that there is pass-through
income Donald Trump's tax proposal would
create a new twenty five percent tax
rate for pass-through income that's the
situation I'm in with the show but that
doesn't mean that it's good economics if
my taxes go down for the income that
passes through to me on the program then
I am more incentivized not to invest
that money into the show think about it
if you lower the rate I can keep the
show's money at I am more likely to keep
the show's money I think if I wanted to
do an expansion of the show or new
programming or get better equipment or
what
ever the money I spend will reduce the
taxes to zero on that expenditure I'm
more likely to do that if taxes are
higher and I'm not suggesting that I
actually make decisions based on tax
rates very few businesses actually do
but this concept that if you lower the
tax rate on businesses all of a sudden
they're going to reinvest a ton of that
money into the economy is just not true
now depending on my personal financial
situation or someone else's I might
spend that extra money that I get to
keep I might save that extra money that
I get to keep but that the decision made
at the personal level and the stimulus
that these folks claim will happen from
lowering the corporate tax rate just
will not happen the entire supply-side
tax cut right-wing thing is merely a
ruse and it's a ruse that Trump and his
friends will be able to save a lot of
money with the amount of money that
Trump and his buddies will be able to
keep if this tax plan goes through is
absolutely stunning and will actually
have a report on that coming up as to
how much Trump's cabinet would save if
this tax plan actually happened